[Music]
country singer Kylie Ray Harris has died
the 30 year old musician was involved in
a three vehicle car crash in New Mexico
on Wednesday I just got to Taos New
Mexico and I'm playing this festival
here called dance I love this festival
Kylie was on a road trip to a music
festival at the time and was documenting
the journey just hours before her death
including this now eerie and emotional
story for those of you who don't know I
spent the last 20 years of my life like
coming to Taos with my dad and my sister
my grandparents lived here my uncle
still lives here but basically literally
every buddy that was here has passed
away
except for my uncle and including my dad
and sorry Instagram but like driving
these roads today like you would think
I've been driving for almost 12 hours
and you would think like that's so
exhausting and boring but like the last
couple of hours like driving through the
mountains and just like remembering my
place in the backseat as a little kid
when my dad was making these treks here
like and I started getting really sad so
I get real sad and then our and then all
of a sudden these random cows like show
up in the middle of the road and that
might sound really crazy but like there
was this time it was like something we
always talked about with my dad and my
sister I was in the backseat asleep when
I was like 10 or 12 and we hit something
really hard and I was like and I like
popped up my head and I was like what
was that if my dad said kalgard but
really he had hit a cow I know that's
very depressing but just the fact that I
started like when I was on my trek
through the mountains I just started
crying and I was
sad and all of a sudden these like cows
just appeared out of nowhere and uh you
know we grieve in different ways but
like I don't know Kylie's publicist
released a statement after the news
broke passing along this message
everyone that knew Kylie knew how much
she loved her family and beyond that how
much she loved music the best tribute to
her unmatched enthusiasm for both is to
spread as much love as you can today and
listen to music that fully inspires you
the rising star released new music just
a few months ago
including a song called 20 years from
now about her hopes for the future and
her six-year-old daughter Corby
[Music]
your friggin
the choice
I
[Music]